C'est bien en salle B15 la réunion, c'est ça ?
Oui, c’est ça.
Tu sais que ça fait 17 fois qu’ils la décalent cette réunion?
*rire*
Excuse moi.
Quoi, qu’est-ce que t’as?
Pardon, je craque.
*rire en fond*
quoi il c'est passé quoi
De toute façon c’est grillé, c’est n’importe quoi.
C’est une caméra cachée.
Arrête de déconner.
*aplodicement*
Oh ta mère.
*rires*
C’est toi qui l’as fait?
Du coup y’a pas réu?
*rires*
Non, ça y’a pas réu, non.
A vrai dire y’a pas d’entreprise non plus.
C’est un canular! On t’a piégé.
De quoi? Ça fait longtemps?
Ça fait combien de temps ?
Ca y est, il sait?
C’est bon ça va, tu peux y aller.
Putain, tu me fais trop rire mec!
Eh, à un moment j’étais là, rue Bergère.
T’avais quoi, 12/13 piges?
J’avais ma grosse caméra de l’époque,
et ben écoute mon vieux.
T'es passé devant moi, t’as rien capté!
*rires*
J’avoue, j’ai pas trop vu, j’ai …
Quoi, attends, 12 ans?
J’étais au collège là.
Oh oui, l’école! C’est une pure idée ça.
T’étais drôle!
Tous les matins, 6h du mat, 5 fois dans la semaine.
Dis toi bien, on me paye, même moi je le fais pas.
Mais vous foutez de ma gueule là, c’est pas…
Oh le pire c’était les maths. Lulu, c’était quoi le truc …?
La trigonométrie!
Ah! La trigunu, la trigounom...
Haha, j’arrive même pas à le dire
tellement c'est n'importe quoi.
Quoi, mais attends, vous avez pas tout inventé,
c’est super utile pour calculer un angle …
Ta gueule, c’est utile de rien du tout.
Les nombres imaginaires!
Les nombres imaginaires, c’est dit dans le titre
pour te mettre la puce à l’oreille,
et toi tu vois rien.
Les nombres ils sont imaginaires putain!
*rires*
Mais moi on m’a dit que ça existait, je sais pas …
Le mec, tu lui dis de sauter d’un bus, il plonge!
Eh, attends, regarde.
Dis lui pour le lait, le lait c’est génial.
Le lait des vaches qui sort des gros pis dégueulasses là.
T’as cru que ça se buvait.
Mais personne ne boit du lait.
Si, oui, à la limite un veau.
On l’a même fait pourrir une fois pour voir
et on a appelé ça: «fromage».
Paf! Toi t’en as bouffé toute ta vie.
Non, non, non, vous ne m’avez quand même pas menti
depuis que je suis né.
Je suis pas con, j’ai des souvenirs …
T’as des souvenirs d’avant tes 4 ans?
Non, non mais …
Normal, c’est parce qu’on vient au monde à l’âge de 4 ans.
La période de gestation chez l’humain c’est 9 mois ET 4 ans.
Et c’est pas systématiquement la femme qui porte l’enfant.
On peut choisir.
Et tu lui as dit qu’on pouvait tisser des toiles?
Des trucs comme ça.
Quoi?
Non mais ça...
Tout le monde a ça.
Moi aussi j’ai des pouvoirs?
Ah non. Toi t’as le sida.
Quoi?
Non je déconne!
*rires général*
La naïveté du gars. Il gobe tout !
Mange pas ça! Mange pas ça, crache!
C’est dégueulasse, c’est de la merde.
Quoi?
C’est du caca.
On en a mis dans les arbres
pour faire genre c’est un fruit, mais...
c’est de la merde.
C’est de la crotte.
C’est de la matière fécale.
Qui sort du cul des gens.
Mais non, n’importe quoi,
moi quand je chie ça ressemble pas à ça.
Toi c’est des trucs marrons qui …?
Ouais, pense à voir un médecin quand même.
T’as cru qu’Apple c’était une vraie marque
et que c’était stylé en plus!
Et il épluchait de la merde.
Et il faisait des tartes avec le gros craspouille.
Craspouille!
Eh, regardez qui voilà.
Maman.
Ouais mais alors, pour le coup là,
vraiment, ta mère c’est pas ta mère.
C’est un animatronic.
Et pendant tout ce temps,
t’as même cru que Clément c’était Rémy,
alors que Rémy, c’était Clément!
On a switché.
C’est comme pour ta meuf.
Ben, c’est pas ta meuf.
C’est une biche.
*fou rires*
*bruit d'explosion*
Bon ben c’est pas tout ça.
On s’est bien fendu la gueule
mais on va peut-être pas camper là!
Allez hop, tous à son poste!
*musique épic*
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passe, vous allez où là?
Retour à la réalité mon gars.
Bienvenue dans le vrai monde.
*tire laser*
*tire de mitraillette*